Devi was Argentina is not exactly having
its best moments.
Okay.
Mauricio Macri has,
government has had to ask for a bailout
from the International Monetary Fund.
And the truth is this,
in the last few decades,
crises,
devaluations,
inflation and payment suspensions has
become commonplace in Argentina as
politics and the economy.
Well,
throughout this entire process,
one political movement has had an
absolute influence.
Perrona isn't it?
All right.
What exactly is this political stream
known as Peronas and how did it come
about and what impact has it really has
on Argentina?
Well,
we're going to talk about it all on
visual politic in two videos and in the
first one we're going to focus on its
origins and its identity.
So listen up.
Yeah.
First of all,
who was Kwan Domingo,
Peron,
and most importantly,
how did he manage to gain power and
influence in Argentine politics for
seven decades?
Well,
it's the beginning of this story.
We have to go all the way back to the
1930s that time Argentine nationalism
was in its golden age,
Argentina.
It was undoubtedly Latin America's great
power,
just like the 1929 crisis.
It was still one of the 10 richest
countries in the world and wages were
much,
much higher than in Europe.
How has the way to second tier,
because in spite of this,
the 1929 crisis had taken its toll
hitting the country hard.
The tension led to the first military
coup in 1930 [inaudible] support is by
many political,
economic and social sectors,
especially on the conservative side of
things.
This militaristic authoritarians
nationalists,
Panorama,
it's became customer ether.
Many officers of the origin time,
Amit did,
he sent to Germany and Italy to take
advanced courses.
Debbie,
what do you know who one of these
officers was?
Well,
yeah,
that would be Juan Domingo Peron who was
sent to you.
It's a a country where he met and
studied firsthand how Benito
Miscellaneous governments was organized
and you know what?
Soon after he'd get the chance to put
this knowledge right into practice,
you see as the beginning of the 1940s
Argentina was under the control of a
corrupt and authoritarians governments
and governments that had perpetuated
electoral fraud and attempted to stay in
power at all costs under these
circumstances.
On June the fourth of 1943 a group of
young officers in the Argentine army
held a coup to tar supposedly to restore
a transparent electoral system.
One of these offices was our
protagonist,
leftenant Colonel Hon Domingo Peron.
Yeah.
By the way,
this was Argentina's second cue to tar
off to the 1930s one but don't think it
was.
It's lost.
Certainly not the case.
During the next 30 years.
The country has suffered for more keys.
The case is dear viewers that it was
this 1943 q which opens the doors to
politics and power for lefthand and
Colonel [inaudible] Domingo Peron.
We can practically see that this is
where Argentina's modern history began.
So listen up
two and a half years that the military
government lasted Paranas Korea was
meteoric.
This was despite the fact that until
then had held a very low rank positions
such as head of the Department of Labor,
a position that in principle was mad.
Do I say it's rather bureaucratic?
However,
hold on a second because thanks to his
political intelligence product managed.
You can use this position as a
springboard for his rise to power.
You see it from the very beginning,
quantum and go [inaudible] and used
everything had learned on the Benito
Mussolini in Italy starting by winning
some of the unions support that way each
time the labor department's had to
intervene in a conflict between
employers and unions related to
[inaudible],
the former.
The employers would almost always lose.
As you can imagine,
this meant that this man's popularity
didn't stop grabbing.
In fact,
shortly after I put on was appointed
minister of war and then vice
presidents,
or without forgetting the labor policies
and the unions,
because if something was very,
very clear to this leftenant colonel,
it was that that would be as political
springboard.
He wasn't the only one aspiring to power
and so much prominence led to a lot of
jealousy.
So much so that the military leaders
asked him to move away from the
governments in 1945 so we could perhaps
expect this to be the ends of this
military man's political career.
Rice.
Well,
no,
nothing could be further from the truth
on had learned how much influence the
media could have in Europe.
So he asked his superiors if he could
say goodbye through the national radio
network.
They naively accepted in Parana,
took full advantage of this opportunity
in his farewell.
She thinks the working passes for that
support and the questions,
the continuity of the social benefits
that had removed.
Paul,
Hey Paul,
bobby,
hello.
It has a huge effect.
In the following days,
the unions mobilized in his favor.
Ends on October the 17th thousands of
workers occupied the plaza de Mayo,
the nerve center of Argentine politics,
the government disorientated.
By the way,
events unfolded,
asked for you.
Leftenant colonel himself to appease the
masses and this is something he did,
but only after agreeing that he'd be a
candidate in the next elections.
He also made sure that he had the
support of the public powers.
Why does it make you,
it person has managed to become a
candidate,
but now he needed to win the election.
We've seen at the time Argentina was
under military control,
so governments authorization was
required to hold meetings and electoral
act when no accident.
Sure.
Goals per ron's campaign actions were
almost automatically authorized.
Well,
his opponent swelled for,
let's just say the process was much
slower and not only that,
but Peran also had complete access to
the most important means of
communication at the time the national
radio station because it was owned by
the government,
not old man zipper on his insistence
that government's approved paid
vacations for all workers as well as
additional salary at the end of the
year.
These are all things that make you look
very good to your electorate and it was
still a move.
This genius of political strategies an
interest to use very well.
See,
the State Department of the United
States itself intervenes in bronze
rivals,
campaigns publishing gay reports known
as the Blue Book,
well put on his activities and those of
his military allies were shown to
support the Nazi regime.
However,
brawn managed to turn this around since
morphed into something like a struggle
between himself who represented
Argentines sovereignty in the United
States.
In the end is all these tactics copied
to years later by populist governments
throughout Latin America won the
elections for per on the victory.
It wasn't overwhelming,
but it was enough.
Very important factor.
When Kwanza Mingo Peron came to
governments.
Argentina was one of the 10 most
prosperous and richest economies in the
wells.
The country.
It was even an international credits are
countries like the United Kingdom
actually owed him money.
Thanks to all of this.
The new president's had more than enough
resources to launch his political
program.
A program based on three pillars,
political sovereignty,
economic independence,
and social justice.
In practice,
he transforms Argentina into a kind of
army under the command of a single
leader.
It's president,
they'll spur on,
managed him,
nationalize a lot of companies,
especially those related to public
services such as transport,
energy and communications.
He also plays to banking under
governmental control into proved a lot
of foreign trade restriction
and he also achieved a lot of popular
support.
So how did he do it?
Well,
he did it by maintaining utility rates
even below that cost and hiring a lot of
employees for the governments.
And for governmental companies,
and it's certainly not so much of a
coincidence that the coach and has 60
years later,
I did practically the same thing.
Of course,
all of this involved a lot of spending
and well,
how do you think he financed it?
Of course he started printing your money
and this is where the addiction of
Argentinian politicians printing bills
came from.
The fact is that during the first years
of this entire process,
and thanks to all the money that he
injected into the economy,
things seemed to be actually sealing
pretty smoothly.
So what was the problem?
Well,
it simply wasn't sustainable.
The government over spends and the
country's competitiveness began to sink
like the titanic.
Within a few years,
they're positive balance,
vanished.
Private investment collapsed.
And so suddenly at some prices started
to skyrocket.
Yes.
So what do you think happened then?
Do you think that given that his
revolution didn't seem to be on the
right track,
per on foot,
take a bit of the blame?
Well,
no,
he didn't at all.
In fact,
he blamed alleged speculators of
attacking the national economy and to
remedy all of this,
he multiplies the government,
controls regulated prices and
implemented all kinds of measures that
would even affect red distribution.
The crisis wasn't Peron's only problem.
The 1853 constitution didn't allow for a
politician to stay in power preventing
an immediate reelection.
So under this scenario,
what do you think he did?
Well,
listen to this.
Along with the bill printing machine,
Latin American politicians.
Second toy is constituents,
reforms,
bands.
Of course,
Bron was no exception in 1949 since the
previous constitution imposed to too
many obstacles to on launched a complete
constitutional reform.
The new constitution placed the state is
the fundamental pillar of Argentinian
society.
Even in the constitution's own preamble,
the three pillars of Juan Domingo Peron
is political thesis were included.
This,
we're supposed to be a constitution for
all,
but let's take a look at the changes
result.
It's
investments or disappeared.
The macro data just got worse.
The country was in crisis and it's
public companies in Argentina underwent
swats the Dvsa,
the Venezuelan state owned oil and
natural gas company underwent,
they simply weren't invested in,
so they suffered from all kinds of
influences and in the end they were very
unproductive and inefficient all to the
detriment of the origin time.
Well,
it's the new model.
Domingo Peron,
the Dimsum,
it became a poverty making machine.
Of course,
this all happens under the enormous
cults of this leader.
The reality to viewers,
the Argentine society was in crisis and
it was so fragmented.
There's under these circumstances,
in September of 1955 there was a new coo
to top.
This time it was against quantum
domingo.
You got it?
Okay.
No,
look,
Moses Ninguna readiness spending
[inaudible] [inaudible].
It's the same time you want to get
pixels.
Zane,
I might be thinking,
well,
this is the ends of for wrong.
Well,
if you think in that your actually
mistaken budget.
We're going to talk about all of that in
a future video and I really hope you
enjoyed this video.
If you did,
please do hit that like button and don't
forget to subscribe to our channel for
brand new videos.
Also,
please do check out our patrion off
channel is possible because of the
people who support us over there.
So find a link to that in the
description below.
And as always,
thank you for watching.